[Music]
welcome back to another episode of
careful boys we are lucky enough to have
with us today twada bay
[Applause]
what's going on in vietnam right now
um
i don't know
that's why you're here you're talking
about you're leaving to the vietnam oh
yeah you're going to the end of the year
end of the year because i'm bringing 40
people to vietnam
with me yeah like 40 followers
how do you know 40 of your followers
this is like a thing actually like
a one week trip split in or two week
trip split in half so 20 will come the
first trip 20 will come the next trip
wow um can we be like five right here
that just on one group they already paid
okay what about we pay and we just
follow them we buy them out yeah yeah
can we buy them out i'm dead you guys
can just like come and like hang out not
the same i don't know we want to be
invited wait you're trying to ruin 40
people's lives
yes
what is it is this like a culinary food
tour type thing kind of it's like it's
culinary because we're going to like the
rice fields and then we're learning um
how to cook from the farmers we're going
to like this fishing town learning how
to cook from the fishermen
and then we're actually gonna go to like
the war museum just to learn a little
bit more about like the vietnam war just
because i feel like nobody over here
really knows what the vietnam war was
about and how it was like so
i mean i love coming back to vietnam and
i love documenting it um
this is just like another way to
um i guess spread my culture to other
people yeah
how do you think a big idea is just
gonna say that like where you come up
with these like dope things to do yeah
how do you do that because for me i'm
like dude did you see the mcdonald's
chicken sandwich
and he calls all his homies we're gonna
go get the new mcdonald's chicken
sandwich cause i really want to spread
my culture bringing 40 people to vietnam
we're thinking about 40 piece nuggets so
when i when i brainstorm on a piece of
paper
it's like
i go what's dope i draw a circle right
and then the first thing that comes out
i'm like
make chicken
how does yours get like damn 40 people
like war tour and all this other war
tour tour
40 person wards war in vietnam dude like
my ideas i just write them down as like
it's already happening like i just
believe that it happened already so it's
like
i'm going to be rich as [ __ ] or [ __ ]
like that i'll write it down um i know
that i've always wanted to bring my
friends over to vietnam so i'm just like
what if there's a thing
where i can actually take people that
watch my videos to vietnam because
that's a really really cool experience
yeah um so
i just kind of told my manager briefly
about it and then um we found a company
to like basically put the whole thing
together so it's like a tour company and
they're like you're gonna give us free
customers oh yes please yeah that's cool
and everybody pays for their own way so
everybody pays for like the ticket the
ticket um
involves like
all the activities the food and
everything all the expenses yeah
experience they just need to get their
flights
but you probably have like
way more people than 40 how do you like
select who wins yeah um how do you know
those people aren't gonna be like crazy
that's another thing how do you vet so
like they do a background check on
everybody just to make sure that like
nobody's like crazy or like a history of
like uh yeah anything
and then
they have
they have their instagram so then i just
like go through and i like kind of just
stalk them and see if they're like
weirdos or not you know you only pick
the hottest 40 people exactly because
you're like i don't want no uglies in
the crew it's like love island and [ __ ]
it's like the bomb is people she picks
up like 40 dudes
she's like i swear it's not it's just a
coincidence to be honest i tried to pick
like girls oh that's just so i could
feel more comfortable for sure
yeah
smart yeah
same i only pick boys because i want to
feel comfortable too
do you think people would pay for uh you
know if we brought people to monterey
park and just was like honestly they
would they would they would like crazy
who
there's people that would be so down for
jk tour type yes and we get the mayor to
like walk them around you guys should
absolutely do so the company that you
got to put together if they want to like
have a test run on some uh you know
local spots yeah local spots you know
some a little bit more inland bowling
alleys
this is a real legit tourist destination
for mainland chinese there's that's why
there's always tour bus stopping here
you're right it is yeah this office this
office this is one of the stops this is
mainland china junior right
just this area in general yeah
unfortunately yes now unfortunately yes
it wasn't always that way god damn it no
it's okay they brought their expensive
big cars and they're like supreme drops
they bring it all over here now you know
and they got their sichuan food in the
northern chinese food here so yeah it's
good
i'm just like those people that are like
i miss how my neighborhood used to be
because it used to be like mainly hong
kong and vietnamese you're wearing
overalls and holding a samurai sword how
my neighborhood used to be you're so
diverse all in one guy
that's why i had to run away to hawaii
dude
wait so you're staying in vietnam for
how long for like a month and a half and
how long is the tour uh the tour is only
like um two weeks long so it's one week
one group one week another group and the
same just do your own thing is it the
same city no so it's saigon da nang um
and that's it i've been to all time
dude
you gangster for real why because you're
supposed to say ho chi minh city oh
not while we're over here oh yeah that's
true over here it's the where the yellow
flag with the north
china be we can say saigon
trying to be
that's like south central like we grew
up here right so we could say south
central but if you're new you got to say
south l.a now
oh yeah that is so true
south central since i was a baby that is
so true oh you can't say south central
because i guess it's like bad
connotation because like you know when
they describe like the street takeovers
they don't it sounds worse when it's
south central street takeovers they just
want south la street takeover well i
don't even register south l.a he's been
researching the takeovers this guy you
can't say south central no you're not
supposed to it's like
being not pc it's like saying saigon
you know oh
no
i could still say it
bart still says it he's still close i
remember i remember as a kid going to
vietnam just being in the middle of like
a grocery area in saigon and then um
being like oh is this saigon mama don't
say that um
i've never got corrected
oh that's interesting they don't say ho
chi minh city here and they don't use
the red flag they don't do it yeah of
course they don't but on instagram it's
the red flag with the yellow stripe with
the star for when you're picking flags
for yeah for the vietnamese you know
what's crazy in taiwan right like the
locals they have an n word for
mainlanders what is it uh weiss and then
it's like what they they'll hear your
accent and they're like
oh
and they're looking up and down i'm dead
and then they're like
yeah yeah yeah but then it's like a
white guy like oh look at all these
chicks they're so friendly
look at all these chicks so are like are
like rappers out there using that in
lyrics they should oh that'd be so funny
i don't even know they should they
should
all this infighting
because the stranger's looking at it
like you guys are the same people right
i know isn't that funny like from the
outside everyone's internal conflicts
look like that right yeah that's why we
need alien invaders to come in because
we could all unify yeah finally be like
oh wait a minute we all the same two eye
[ __ ] or maybe they've been
trying to invade and they're like oh man
these guys are already [ __ ]
themselves at a certain point probably
they're just waiting till we all kill
our kill each other off they're like
okay who are lizards though don't we
have like lizards on our planet like
growth lizards did you see who are
lizards yeah who were they oh you mean
the the the reptilians yeah the
reptilians
the reptilian aliens you ever heard of
them they're the illuminati though the
reptilian the reptilians are the
illuminati and the aliens at the same
time i don't know dude
it's impossible
it's hard to keep up with q and on like
stuff like it's changing all the time i
feel like they're just the teenage
mutant ninja turtles that people just
like really blew out of proportion i
don't think so i think their whole it's
something dude the reptilian people
they're shape-shifters dude only going
to watch alex jones why would they pick
being reptiles all the time yeah what is
the theory on the reptiles you got a
deep dive dude and it's like it's like
an ancient race that controls like
everything that happens and they think
they're reptiles because like it goes
back to you know like the ancient
paintings and the the carvings there's
always like some [ __ ] like lizard
head dude like in the [ __ ] egyptian
tombs and [ __ ] you know yeah it's all
because some guy couldn't draw a face
correctly
probably i could draw a lizard sick
though
lizard's like a dude
go ahead human face i don't know i feel
like i was walking around and i kept
seeing your name on like outsides of
like certain restaurants of like you can
get like a toy to bay like special thing
where where are your like toyota bay
things located hokey something yeah yeah
so it's um it's a collab with sweet fin
oh i know sweet fan yeah they have like
15 locations in southern california so
la orange county san diego south central
um yeah you can get it there too
wherever that is we don't know south
away yeah it's south l.a it's on like
the little like there's like a sign on
the sidewalk
yeah and it was like yo that's tight
that's toy to bay man thank you you've
been rushing i see all over the place
doing food things here over here over
here hey why not that's awesome so what
do you get at sweet fin that's like a
toy to bay like so i made a bowl with
them where i gave them my fish sauce
recipe which i've never seen in like a
poke bowl so you know how like we have
vermicelli bowls so
it's just that but like with poke
oh [ __ ] yeah so
vermicelli um pickle daikon and carrots
your protein of choice
and then i got the fish sauce so when a
when a when a restaurant wants a partner
with you and they're like we're going to
do a toy to bay like special thing how
do you pick which thing out of all the
stuff that you could make that you think
represents like she goes straight to
fish sauce absolutely yeah i think i
just um i just
see what they have going on on their
menu and then take inspiration from that
and see what i can um bring in from my
culture
usually fish sauce um and then
incorporate that into
their menu so whenever you go to certain
restaurants like just random restaurants
does your mind already go to this like
business mentality we were like i wonder
what a toyota bay thing would be here um
sometimes but most of the times it's
like if i can take inspiration and um i
i will recreate like a recipe from like
that meal if like i really wanted to
like i went to an indian place um called
bombay beach and they have this like
indian fish and chips which was really
interesting because it's like their take
on fish and chips it's not like the
regular fish and chips that you're
thinking of yeah it's battered fish and
fries but instead of just like
dipping it in like a tartar sauce or
whatever they coat it in this like thick
indian sauce
so kind of like a fish and chips um
orange chicken kind of vibe so then i
was like oh
i think i can do this but make it like a
gakha which is like a vietnamese dish
that's um
like a catfish braised so i can take
that sauce i love it is that the one in
the clay pot and it's like sweet yes it
has pineapples and [ __ ] sometimes i know
you're talking yeah so like i was like
what if i do that but instead of like
the coating that they put i can use the
gakhau coating to make my fish and chips
if uh afters was like we want to make an
ice cream flavor for you would it be
fish sauce
um maybe
i actually made it like a fish sauce
caramel brittle that was really
delicious
how would you do this collab let's say
hometown buffets like yeah i was
thinking the same thing we need you we
need you to own an aisle in our
restaurant oh my god
in this aisle hometown buffalo what
would you do what would be the toyota
bay
x hometown buffet it would be like a
aisle of like create your own um broken
dish or a broken rice plate oh it was
done
it's prepped in her mind yo like we
can't even surprise her yeah yeah that
sounds good already didn't hotel buffet
go out of business just buy it out and
call it hometown toyota bay hometown
she has a better name already i'm
talking about play that sounds
vietnamese already all right what about
uh what about a starbucks drink a
starbucks drink um i feel like a
vietnamese coffee is really
like
is so predictable so [ __ ] that a fish
sauce coffee but but but but but but but
there's there's there's but there's but
there's junebe
there's junebe there's there's there's
this thing that we actually are a
partner of hey cut the deal
yeah what what would you do for them
any brainstorm ideas that you have fish
sauce mcchicken
oh yeah vermicelli in a cup
i am a really big fan of like the coffee
and tea
collab oh like dirty dirty child like we
have a ton of dirty drinks a dirty
matcha but with vietnamese coffee and
maybe we can do like a fish sauce
caramel
um what about a frappuccino
so you drink fur through a straw right
that sounds really good because like
there's starnese there's cinnamon in
there like you can really get like the
fragrances going noodles and then the
rare steaks maybe not that
all right all right for this one i feel
like this is a boba stroller this one's
probably a little realistic so you
probably already have it in your head
yeah what is the toy to babe mcdonald's
collab oh
it would have to be like a a specific
sauce
because i already know that like my meal
would just be mcchicken
um uh chicken nuggets and fries and a
sprite like that oh you like all chicken
stuff yeah
are you are you do you already have a
toy sauce
um what do you mean like is there like a
a consumer packaged good so i'm actually
going to vietnam to work on
it bro i solved the riddle that's why
she's there for so long
so after yeah so after the trip the
two-week trip i'm gonna be working on my
cookbook like taking photos over there
and then also going to work on the side
that would be so funny if those 40
people are just her focus group she's
just force feeding it no more seeing him
thoughts that's hilarious i want to see
some signs uh no
when are we gonna go see the ocean i'm
gonna get a side of rice at least
just pierce this sauce yeah
yo that's tight dude your own sauce
let's go can you give us any hints on
what kind of sauce it's gonna be fish
sauce all right sorry he won't yelling
that well that's like the biggest that's
the biggest hit oh yeah but what's gonna
be the best for you know the what the
dancer like what's the what's the
difference like what the special oh
yeah speaker language it's because i
speak about northern vietnamese it's
because it's me
who's making it
so that's what version is
miami
i go around and i just like dip my hands
in there for extra toy germs
[Laughter]
you gotta pay extra for that you know
what something very simple but i always
salivate when you make it
are your breakfast eggs oh my god oh my
god
hands down
ever since my vietnamese friends taught
me that style and then like you know if
i like sleep over whatever their mom
would just like bust out a [ __ ] you just
toast out a baguette
and i'm like how'd you get this [ __ ] so
crispy and i just watch her make it and
it's just hella like just oil
and then high heat flash it real quick
and i'm like dude that's how i eat eggs
now and then like um i just put some
fish sauce on the top that's it yeah you
put fish sauce yeah i don't drink soy
sauce i do soy sauce i do fish sauce and
black pepper
yeah sometimes i do japanese style and i
mixed two cultures i put like soup base
have you heard of meme um or or or just
soy sauce sometimes if i feel like it
yeah yeah but i think crispy
sunny side up is the way to go it's the
best egg it's the best literally with a
french baguette or or just a french loaf
a little bunny
why is that so good it's so simple but
it's so good because i know what it
tastes like too so when you make it i'm
like oh that's gonna crunch at the
bottom and oh yeah cause that's the
taste of the true economy class
watching her like cooking content like
if someone was looking at you third
person you look like you're watching
porn right
you're just like oh yeah oh
oh my god like food wars and then you're
honorably going i love this boy
yeah it's real food porn yeah or just
regular porn too you know to some people
so let's say let's say you go to vietnam
end of this year you spend time uh
obviously there's cookbook stuff there's
the tour for the 40 people and then
you're also working on your sauce uh
when do you feel like you're hopefully
calendar wise gonna have like a sauce
ready for the public yeah yeah next year
oh next year next year q1 q2 kill three
probably q3 because my book comes out q3
so it will be around the same time
simultaneously yeah oh you're probably
gonna use your sauce in your cookbook
too yeah dude your book is going to
slide also you got to do the sauce
at the same time because once it comes
out it's like oh by the way if you buy
this sauce that's in the cookbook baby
and there's a book signing we're also
forced feeding your sauce exactly
spoonful every autograph do you ever
think i'd do a perfume version of your
sauce you know that's funny this is
going to smell real good
she's like that's funny i already
thought of that yeah she's like that's
also what i'm going to vietnam that's
one of the process dude you should the
ink from the pen that you signed the
books should be the sauce so people go
here's a weird question even though i
know completely you could have your own
tv show whatever you want are there any
existing cooking shows on like networks
right now that if they asked you to be a
part of it you would say yes i i'm
actually working on a show right now i
knew it knew it with um buzzfeed tasty
oh
[ __ ] that's dope that's all i can say
damn dude that is so that much feels so
good to have so many things that you
can't tell people yeah like that's like
you just feel so tinted something else
that you can't talk about
i got a hell of a [ __ ] going on too yeah
we gotta toss twitter
like crazy
anyways
fish sauce
give us a hint give us in i'm working
with instagram i'll get my account back
what happened yo congrats bro that's
what happened let's take dudes in the
works
have you been talking to somebody on the
inside he's been de-platforming so damn
it's funny because it's believable apart
yeah that's so funny
as for you to show up to someone else's
podcast and be like what do you got
going on well
just trying to get my instagram back so
hoping for the best
speaking if anybody if anybody from
instagram out there [ __ ] verify me
you dicks oh you're not very instagram
is so
weird
like so so weird so
it took me like two years to get the
check
mark how did i get it before you because
you're more established
no
you know
there's only one jojitsukawa in the
world i think i don't deserve a blue
checkmark you see my post i post like
once every two months the world needs to
know that that's joe so they can watch
out you know why do you think anthony
hasn't been verified i have no idea he's
like
on tv and [ __ ] yeah dude they're so
weird they're so so weird you hang out
with
you
know
josh
i need to make a fish sauce that's where
i need it does it really affect your
stuff though if you have if you have a
blue chip oh yeah if you're working
emotionally yes if you're working with
brands yes
yeah and also my name's common
like anthony and lee so like there's a
bunch of like other random anthony yeah
there's no other every race
yeah every race has an anthony league
when you submit do you have any like
articles i'm sending different articles
i've submitted three times now so it's
like now now i just need a plug new
articles just came out so i'm okay cool
let me try and send it well i'll give
you my contact at facebook then
that's how i got mine that's nice this
whole time this whole time
he's like his name's mark the whole time
yeah mark zeke his name's mark z yeah
yeah yeah
called the zucks dude i got a funny
story about that
[Music]
foreign